bonjour
aujourd'hui on va parler de rouge
oh et du désir alors ils se trouvent
rousseau n'est pas particulièrement
connu du grand public pour ses écrits
sur le désir il est davantage connu pour
ses écrits politiques pour sa théorie du
contrat social également pour son traité
d'éducation les 1000 qui d'ailleurs a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre quand on
sait que rousseau a lui-même abandonné
ses enfants à l'assistance publique
mais comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
dans une précédente vidéo s'intéresser à
la pensée d'un philosophe ne signifie
pas que l'on cautionne ces agissements
personnels et on peut très bien apprécié
la valeur d'une pensée indépendamment
des agissements de son auteur rousseau a
écrit sur la politique
il a écrit sur l'éducation il a
également écrit sur le bonheur est
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à un
texte de rousseau extraits de son oeuvre
la nouvelle héloïse dans lequel rousseau
va nous exposer sa conception du désir
et plus particulièrement sa conception
du rapport entre désir et bonheur mais
avant de s'intéresser à ce texte
on va d'abord faire un rappel en
précisant que dans l'histoire de la
pensée
deux conceptions principal du désir se
sont affrontés alors évidemment je
schématise dans les faits les choses
sont toujours plus nuancée plus complexe
mais si on veut comprendre ce qui fait
l'originalité de la position de rousseau
sur le désir je pense qu'il est
important de comprendre dans les grandes
lignes
comment le désir a été perçue est défini
dans l'histoire des idées donc pour ça
on va commencer par faire un retour à
l'antiquité une période dans laquelle le
désir ne bénéficiait pas d'un statut
extrêmement positif contrairement à
l'époque moderne où le désir est plutôt
quelque chose qui est valorisé car que
serait une vie sans désir dans
l'antiquité les choses étaient vues de
manière un petit peu différente
en effet le désir correspondait à ce que
les grecs appelaient le pathos pathos
qu'on retrouve dans pathologie le pathos
c'est la passion et la passion c'est se
fasse à quoi nous sommes passif la
passion c'est le sentiment que nous
subissons c'est le sentiment qui nous
tombe dessus
c'est le sentiment face auquel nous
perdons notre pouvoir de contrôler la
passion nous rend passif la passe
on nous fait perdre la maîtrise de nous
mêmes et en ce sens la passion est
quelque chose qui s'oppose à la liberté
de l'individu
elle s'oppose à sa liberté car elle
s'oppose à sa raison or pour les anciens
la liberté est le produit de la raison
humaine la liberté c'est la capacité à
s'autodéterminer dans ses actions et
cette autodétermination ne peut être
issue que de la raison obéir à ses
passions obéir à ses désirs
c'est perdre le pouvoir de la raison ces
dons perdre le pouvoir de
s'autodéterminer
on ne peut être libre que dans la raison
nous disent les anciens et la passion
apparaît comme la marque de notre
servitude
donc je disais que le désir est un
pathos et cette idée on la retrouve
principalement chez les stoïciens les
stoïciens qui nous invite à la maîtrise
de nos passions à la maîtrise de nos
émotions et de nos désirs et plus
particulièrement des désirs de ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous désiré ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous c'est le meilleur
moyen de se rendre malheureux désirer ce
qui n'est pas nous c'est faire dépendre
notre bonheur du caprice de la fortune
du caprice du hasard désiré ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous c'est abandonner
notre pouvoir de maîtrise c'est
abandonner tout ce qui dépend de nous à
travers le désir ce qui s'exprime c'est
un manque le manque de l'objet absent
car qu'est-ce qu'un désir sinon la
marque de l'absence le désir c'est la
marque de l'absence c'est la marque de
ce que l'on n'a pas et que l'on voudrait
obtenir le désirent se fixe toujours sur
l'objet manquant
et si on admet cette idée ça signifie
que tout désir est une souffrance tout
désir est une souffrance parce que tout
désir nous rappelle l'absence de ce que
l'on n'a pas tous désirent nous rappelle
notre caractère incomplet
notre absence de plénitude
et observez bien que l'idée de plénitude
c'est le fait d'être plein fait d'être
remplies c'est ce qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs dans le mot content être
contents se contenter c'est être repu
c'est être satisfait c'est être remplies
or le désir c'est l'insatisfaction c'est
le trou à l'intérieur de nous le trou
qui demande à être comblés et donc en
soi le désir est une douleur le désirent
et ce qui nous rappelle que nous ne
sommes pas complet j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'en parler dans d'autres
vidéos mais je vais me répéter dans le
banquet de platon le personnage
d'aristophane nous expose sa conception
de l'amour et du désir
et pour ça il a recours au mythe des
androgynes qu'ils sont des êtres à la
fois mâle et femelle que zeus à couper
en deux pour les empêcher de se mesurer
aux dieux en coupant les androgynes en
deux just venait de créer deux être
incomplets deux êtres qui allait passer
le restant de leur existence à
rechercher leur moitié manquante
d'ailleurs ça c'est beau et touchant
comme histoire parce que dans ce mythe
on nous raconte que lorsque les deux
moitiés se retrouve elle s'en lasse pour
tenter de s'unir et elle n'arrive plus à
se quitter
l'une l'autre elle c'est ce même de
s'alimenter au point qu'elles finissent
par mourir dans les bras l'une de
l'autre
c'était pour ainsi dire la première
version de l'amour romantique de l'amour
passion qui va jusqu'à la mort mais peu
importe ce qu'il faut bien comprendre à
partir de ce mythe c'est cette idée de
parties manquantes
c'est cette idée de recherche de ce qui
nous complète et c'est justement ça le
drame de l'humanité
c'est cette incomplétude c'est cette
finitude qui nous met dans un état
d'insatisfaction permanente qui nous
tire haye qui nous empêchent d'être
reclus qui nous empêchent d'être
satisfait l'être humain est un éternel
insatisfait et toute la culture humaine
n'est que la tentative désespérée de
l'être humain d'accéder à ce qui lui
manque de faire advenir ce qu'il n'a pas
c'est à dire de rechercher la complétude
d'égaler les dieux pour les stoïciens il
existe un moyen légal et les dieux il
suffit de ne plus désiré le plus désiré
c'est ne plus prêter le flanc au manque
c'est ne plus prêter le flanc à
l'insatisfaction c'est réduire le
diamètre du trou qui du coup n'aura plus
besoin d'être comblé lorsqu'on désire
quelque chose le fait de combler ce
désir le fait de l'assouvir ne va faire
que renforcer l'intensité du désir
lorsqu'il va renaître
car c'est ça la malédiction du désir
c'est qu'aussitôt satisfait il
s'empresse de renaître et plus on va le
satisfaire plus il va renaître avec
force plus il va devenir un désir
tyrannique
c'est pour ça que lorsque l'on traite
l'addiction chez quelqu'un on passe par
une phase de sevrage
le sevrage étant la période pendant
laquelle les effets du manque vont se
faire ressentir avec leur intensité
maximale une fois passé le pic de ce
sevrage à ce moment là la dépendance se
fait de moins en moins fortes
donc l'idée c'est de dire que plus on
satisfait un désir et plus on renforce
ce désir et plus on renforce un désir
plus on renforce le manque que ce désir
va nous faire subir pour epicure et les
épicuriens le désir n'est pas quelque
chose qu'il faille rejeter absolument
alors on a souvent tendance à galvauder
la pensée des piqûres en en faisant une
sorte d downeast grossiers qu'ils
recommanderaient de jouir au maximum des
plaisirs de la chair encore on a eu
l'occasion d'expliquer que c'était pas
du tout ça et puis qu'on n'est pas
quelqu'un qui va pousser à la débauche
qui va pousser à la luxure pas du tout
c'est quelqu'un qui préconisait la
modération des désirs et la modération
des plaisirs associé à ses désirs
d'ailleurs ça donne l'occasion de faire
une petite mise au point sémantique
c'est qu'on a souvent tendance
conceptuellement à confondre désir et
plaisir
il ya bien sûr un lien entre les deux
mais ce n'est pas du tout la même chose
le désir c'est le manque de l'objet
absents le plaisir c'est le résultat de
la satisfaction du désir
donc le désir ne produit pas de plaisir
le désir produit un manque il produit
une souffrance et la satisfaction du
désir
c'est à dire l'obtention de l'objet
manquant elle va produire un plaisir
elle va produire une jouissance et 7 800
ce n'est rien d'autre que les effets
compensateurs du manque qui vient d'être
comblée donc on pourrait finalement
presque comparer le plaisir un
soulagement
le plaisir c'est le soulagement du
manque c'est la compensation du manque
donc je disais epicure ne préconise
absolument pas la satisfaction sans
limite de tous nos désirs
au contraire le propre de la philosophie
d'epicure c'est justement de recommander
la modération phrenesis qui s'opposent à
lui brice l'hubris c'est-à-dire
l'illimitation l'hymne modération
l'incapacité à se limiter dans la
satisfaction de ses désirs pour epicure
l'hubris est une véritable pathologie
pour le coup c'est à dire que ça relève
d'un dysfonctionnement d'une incapacité
de l'être humain à se raisonner ça
pourrait piqûre c'est incompatible avec
la sagesse c'est incompatible avec la
démarche du philosophe qui doit être
d'accéder à la quiétude et à la paix
intérieure et pour autant et piqûre
n'est pas aussi radicale que le sont les
stoïciens à savoir qu'il ne rejette pas
le désir par essence mais simplement il
considère qu'il existe différentes
sortes de désir
si vous préférez il considère que tous
les désirs ne se valent pas et s'ils ne
se valent pas on doit pas adopter la
même attitude vis à vis d'eux epicure
distingue trois sortes de désir les
désirs naturel et nécessaire ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui les besoins les
besoins vitaux les besoins
physiologiques parmi lesquels manger
boire dormir et ses désirs là nous dit
epicure doivent être satisfaits les
déserts naturels et nécessaires sont les
satisfait pas on meurt donc il n'y a pas
le choix
on ne peut pas se soustraire des
obligations naturel peut pas se
soustraire des contraintes physiques de
ce monde et donc nous ne sommes pas
libres de nos affranchir de ses besoins
la deuxième sorte de désir chez epicure
ce sont les désirs naturel mais non
nécessaires et ses désirs là nous dit et
piqûres peuvent être satisfaits mais
avec modération
et c'est là qu'on comprend à quel point
la notion de modération est absolument
crucial dans la conception du désir chez
epicure la modération
les ti libre c'est ce qui fait selon
epicure que le plaisir ne va jamais
entraîné de déplaisir un plaisir
satisfait sans modération c'est un
plaisir qui va entraîner des
inconvénients par exemple l'addiction on
en parlait tout à l'heure
l'addiction est une conséquence de la
satisfaction immodéré des désirs c'est
la conséquence d'une absence de contrôle
dans la satisfaction de nos désirs mais
il ya aussi d'autres formes de désir qui
si on les satisfait sans modération vont
entraîner de la souffrance vont
entraîner de la douleur on peut prendre
l'exemple de celui qui va à boire de
l'alcool sans aucune modération et qui
le lendemain matin va peut-être le
regretter à cause de sa gueule de bois
donc ça c'est un exemple qui permet de
comprendre que tout plaisir à sa
contrepartie un faux bien comprendre
cette conception quasi mécaniste du
rapport entre plaisir et douleur un
plaisir immodéré un plaisir au delà du
raisonnable va toujours entraîné selon
les épicuriens une contrepartie négative
le revers de la médaille est donc si on
fait le calcul
si on met en relation le plaisir obtenus
et la douleur occasionnée
on s'aperçoit que ce plaisir n'en est
plus un on s'aperçoit que ce plaisir
entraîne le contraire du plaisir et que
donc il ne doit pas être satisfait voilà
pourquoi la troisième sorte de désir
selon epicure les désirs non naturelle
et non nécessaires doivent absolument
être banni car ce sont des désirs qui
sont fondamentalement incapable de nous
rendre heureux
pour epicure satisfaire ses désirs ça
doit avoir pour but le bonheur est donc
si on est dans une sorte de course
effrénée aux plaisirs sans prendre en
compte la contrepartie de ces plaisirs
là ce moment là on se condamne au
malheur on se condamne au manque on se
condamne aux conséquences négatives de
ces plaisirs et donc finalement on passe
complètement à côté notre objectif on
peut s'arrêter ici pour la conception
ancienne du désir le désir comme pathos
le désir qui doit passer sous le
contrôle de la raison chez les stoïciens
et le désir qui doit être satisfait avec
modération chez les épicuriens et on en
arrive ici à la conception moderne du
désir vous allez voir qu'on va assister
un véritable basculement dans la
représentation du désir on va passer de
la représentation d'un désir qu'il faut
maîtriser qu'il faut garder sous le
contrôle de la raison qu'il faut tenir
en laisse un désir comme qualités
positives de l'être humain et pour le
comprendre il va falloir qu'on comprenne
ce que l'on entend par désir à l'époque
moderne à l'époque moderne
la notion de désir est quasiment un
synonyme de puissance le désir c'est de
la puissance est l'un des premiers
auteurs modernes à défendre cette idée
c'est spinoza spinoza nous explique que
le désir c'est une propriété essentielle
de tous les êtres qui existe et vous
aurez remarqué que je n'ai pas dis
seulement des êtres vivants mais bien
des êtres qui existent de ce que
heidegger appellerait des étangs étant
le participe présent du verbe être des
étangs des choses qui sont qui se
définissent par le fait d'être alors
déjà on va expliquer en quoi le désire
peut être considérée comme une propriété
essentielle des êtres vivants parce que
c'est plus facile à comprendre si on
comprend que la notion de désir renvoie
à ce que d'autres ont appelé l'élan
vital ce que spinoza lui-même appel d'un
terme latin le conatus c'est à dire la
tendance à persévérer dans son être à
persévérer
dans l'existence là ce moment là on peut
comprendre en quoi tout être vivant est
un être de désir le désir ne signifie
ici rien d'autre que le désir de se
conserver le désir de se maintenir dans
la vie notre instinct de conservation et
il est vrai que tout être vivant va
toujours pour suivre sa propre survie et
va toujours lutter pour sa survie
et bien cette force qui nous pousse à
lutter pour notre survie
cette force qui n'ad'autre travail que
de combattre la mort cette force là
c'est le désir
vous voyez qu'on est passé à une autre
définition du désir ça c'est quelque
chose que les philosophes ont très
souvent ils redéfinissent les termes y
compris les termes de l' usage courant
il en donne une nouvelle définition qui
parfois peut nous déconcerter
et ce qui est intéressant dans cette
nouvelle définition du désir selon
spinoza c'est que ce désir là n'a pas
nécessairement d'objets n'a vu tout à
l'heure que le désir était toujours
désir de ce qui nous manque
désir de l'objet absents chez spinoza
le désir est une tendance spontanée
tendance spontanée intérieur à l'être
vivant qui va agir comme le moteur du
maintien dans l'existence c'est ça le
désir le moteur du maintien dans
l'existence est donc là vous allez me
dire d'accord pour les êtres vivants on
peut comprendre cette idée d'un désir
qui nous maintient dans les distances
cet instinct de survie qui fait qu'on va
sans cesse vouloir repousser les limites
de la mort c'est finalement ce désir qui
se manifeste dans l'appétit
le fait d'avoir faim c'est bien
l'expression d'un désir de se maintenir
en vie c'est bien notre corps qui nous
fait éprouver un désir sans lequel nous
nous laisserions littéralement mourir et
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
l'appétit est souvent considérée comme
un signe de bonne santé c'est à dire
l'expression du désir de se maintenir et
de s'affirmer dans l'existence mais
qu'en est il des objets inanimés
qu'en est il des objets qui ne sont pas
traversé par un élan vital parce que
dire que le micro qui est en face de moi
exprime un désir
ça sent très étrange
semblait même complètement loufoque
comment un objet inerte pourrait-il
avoir du désir est bien là encore si on
remplace le mot désir par l'expression
de principe de maintien dans l'existence
maintien dans l'existence matérielle et
à ce moment là il n'est plus totalement
absurde de parler de désir pour un objet
inerte
parce que cet objet inerte qui est en
face de vous ce smartphone cet écran
d'ordinateur
peu importe n'importe quel objet qui est
autour de vous vous êtes bien l'accord
qui se maintient dans l'existence à
chaque seconde
ce que je veux dire par l'arm c'est que
cet objet il ne se dissout pas dans les
airs il reste solide
il reste présent dans l'existence et le
fait que cet objet ne se dissolve pas
dans les airs le fait qu'ils ne
disparaissent pas qu'il ne
s'anéantissent pas c'est la preuve qu'il
est pour ainsi dire
animés d'un principe de maintien dans
l'existence alors oui ce qui fait que
cet objet se maintient dans l'existence
ce sont les molécules qui le composent
qui sont elles mêmes formé d'atomes bien
sûr mais justement justement ce qui fait
que la matière se conservent ce qui fait
que la matière continue d'exister à
chaque seconde qui s'écoule
c'est quelque chose ans maintenant dans
l'existence la matière est active
les molécules sont actives les atomes
sont actifs
l'énergie qui se trouve dans un atome
cette énergie elle existe
factuellement il n'y a pas besoin d'être
physiciens pour admettre cette idée
d'énergie de l'atome autrement dit
d'énergie contenue dans la matière
et bien c'est ça que spinoza appelle le
désir le désir c'est le principe qu'on
trouve au sein même de la matière et qui
explique le maintien de la matière dans
l'existence se maintenir ce n'est pas
rien
c'est l'expression d'une énergie c'est
l'expression d'un désir donc ses skis
qu'on peut dire que chez spinoza le
désir et le principe de tout ce qui
existe
donc vous voyez que c'est quand même au
prix d'un renversement de la définition
du désir qu'on est passé d'un statut
globalement négatif du désir chez les
anciens un statut positif chez les
modernes
la définition que donne espinosa du
désir n'est pas une définition qui a
fait l'unanimité chez les philosophes
qui lui ont succédé donc rigoureusement
parlant il ne serait pas très fidèle à
la réalité de dire que le désir au sens
moderne se réduire et à la définition
qu'en donne espinosa mais c'était
simplement pour vous montrer que les
représentations philosophie du désir ont
varié dans le temps et ça c'est ce qui
va nous permettre de comprendre en quoi
la position de rousseau se trouve à la
croisée des chemins
on va voir en quoi le désir chez
rousseau est à la fois une force mais
une force qui ne réclament pas
nécessairement d'être satisfaites
chez rousseau le désir ne doit pas
nécessairement être satisfait et ça va
même encore plus loin
c'est à dire que pour rousseau c'est
lorsque le désir n'est pas satisfait qu
il nous conduit au bonheur et c'est ça
qui fait l'originalité de la thèse de
rousseau le bonheur c'est la non
satisfaction de son désir car pour
rousseau ce qui conduit au bonheur n'est
pas la satisfaction du désir
ce qui conduit au bonheur c'est le désir
lui-même ce qui conduit au bonheur c'est
le fait de désirer
alors avant de rentrer dans le détail de
cette conception
je vous propose de lire l'extrait de la
nouvelle héloïse dans lequel rousseau
exposé justement cette conception du
rapport entre désir et bonheur je cite
malheur à qui n'a plus rien à désirer il
perd pour ainsi dire tout ce qu'ils
possèdent
on juil - de ce qu'on obtient que de ce
qu'on espère et l'on est heureux
qu'avant d'être heureux en effet l'homme
à vide et bornés fait pour tout vouloir
et peut obtenir a reçu du ciel une force
consolante qui rapproche de lui tout ce
qu'il désire qui le soumet à son
imagination qui le lui rend présent et
sensible qui le lui livre en quelque
sorte
et pour lui rendre cet imaginaire
propriété plus douce le modifie au gré
de sa passion mais tout ce prestige
disparaît devant l'objet lui même rien
embellie plus cet objet aux yeux de son
possesseur
on se figure points ce convoi
l'imagination ne pars plus rien de ce
qu'on possède
l'illusion cesse où commence la
jouissance le pays des chimères et en ce
monde le seul digne d'être habité et
elle est le néant des choses humaines
encore l'être existants par lui-même il
n'y a rien de beau que ce qui n'est pas
qu'est-ce que rousseau essaie de nous
dire à travers ce texte
ils essaient de nous dire quelque chose
d'extrêmement simple c'est que lorsqu'on
désire lorsqu'on désire quelque chose
lorsqu'on désire quelqu'un on ne désire
pas ce quelque chose et on ne désire pas
ce quelqu'un ce qu'on désire c'est la
représentation que l'on s'en fait
rousseau nous dit que dans tout désir
il y a une part d'imagination on imagine
l'objet davantage qu'on le perçoit
autrement dit on désire quelque chose
sans forcément le connaître comme on
peut désirer un plat sans forcément
savoir quel goût il a ce qui veut bien
dire que votre perception a fait naître
en vous une image de la chose une
représentation représentations sur
laquelle va naître votre désir mais
votre désir ne va pas naître d'une
connaissance réelle de la chose
maintenant
appliquons ça au désir envers un autre
être humain au désir que l'on peut
éprouver pour une personne désirée
quelqu'un désirez avoir une relation
sexuelle avec sept personnes désiraient
passer du temps avec elle
partager une relation intime dans tous
les cas il y à l'idée d'une attirance le
désir pour une personne c'est
l'attirance pour cette personne
l'attirance l'attraction c'est ce qui
nous tire vers l'objet et voyez que là
encore on utilise un mot issu du champ
lexical de la physique l'objet agit sur
nous comme un aimant et l'amant est un
aimant mais ce qui nous attire chez la
personne c'est d'abord ce que l'on
perçoit d'elle
est ce que notre imagination va
construire à partir de cette perception
c'est à dire que ce n'est jamais la
perception seul qui alimentent notre
désir notre désir est alimenté par
l'imagination c'est à dire par le
prolongement de la perception par notre
imagination imagination c'est à dire
littéralement le fait de se forger une
image une image par opposition à la
réalité
on retrouve ici
l'idée platonicienne du simulacre de
l'illusion du fantasme
nous désirons chez l'autre l'objet de
notre fantasme nous désirons chez
l'autre les qualités que nous lui
prêtons par notre imagination et donc ce
que nous dit rousseau c'est que quand on
désire quelqu'un on ne désire pas
quelqu'un on désire la projection qu'on
se fait de cette personne on ne désire
pas quelqu'un on désire la
représentation qu'on s'en fait dans son
texte
rousseau décrit l'imagination comme une
force consolante faut bien comprendre ce
que ça veut dire une force consolante
une force consolante c'est la faculté
que nous avons d'adapter notre
perception de la réalité à ce que nous
voudrions qu'elle soit si vous préférez
c'est agréable de se représenter les
choses telles que nous voudrions qu'elle
soit et c'est parce que c'est agréable
que nous avons tous cette tendance à
voir dans les choses
ce que nous voudrions ivoire a projeté
dans l'autre ce que nous voudrions que
l'autre soit et ce faisant nous
augmentons notre désir en réalité ce
n'est pas l'autre qui fait naître le
désir en nous c'est nous qui utilisons
l'autre comme moyen d'alimenter notre
désir mais l'autre n'est qu'un support
de notre désir imaginaire l'autre n'est
qu'une occasion que nous trouvons pour
projeter sur lui ce que nous voulons
c'est ça le propre du désir la
projection de soi dans l'autre on désire
pas l'autre on désire soit dans l'autre
donc voyez il ya vraiment cette idée que
tout désir et la construction d'une
illusion et rousseau ne le dénonce
absolument pas au contraire ils ne le
critiquent pas parce que pour lui ça
participe du processus d'embellissement
ce processus d'embellissement par lequel
on va amplifier les qualités de l'autre
on va parfois même les inventer parce
que ça va rendre notre désir plus
agréable ça va rendre nos pensées plus
douce et donc ça va faire de notre
expérience du désir
une expérience du bonheur
en embellissant l'objet de notre désir
ont fait de notre désir
un bonheur c'est ça l'idée de rousseau
le désir nous conduit au bonheur parce
qu'à travers le processus d'imagination
nous attribuons à la chose ou à la
personne des qualités qu'elle n'a pas
nous la transfigure ont selon notre
idéal et ainsi nous sommes heureux nous
pouvons la contempler ces s'accrocher
le désir la contemplation la
contemplation de l'être idéal par le
désir nous idéalise ont ils encore vous
allez trouver que j'insiste mais
l'étymologie d'idéaliser idéal s'est
transformé en idées idéalisé quelqu'un
c'est lui ôter sa réalité c'est le
transformer en idées c'est le
transformer en abstraction pure celle
anéantir commettre réel quand on désire
l'autre en réalité on ne s'intéresse pas
à l'autre parce que si on s'intéresse à
l'autre on s'intéresserait à ces défauts
on les prendrait en compte
on chercherait pas à se créer un voile
d'illusions entre nous et cette personne
on ne projetterait pas sur elle ce que
nous voudrions qu'elle soit on
chercherait à savoir ce qu'elle est on
cherchera savoir ce qu'elle est mais du
coup ben on la trouverait beaucoup moins
belle on la trouverait beaucoup moins
idéales beaucoup moins conformes au
modèle qui nous plaît nous projetons sur
l'autre un modèle et si on s'aperçoit
que l'autre ne correspond pas à ce
modèle sans s'aperçoit que l'autre ne
répond pas aux attentes que l'on sait
soi même construite par l'imagination
on va alors éprouver de la déception on
va considérer que l'autre a cessé de
répondre à nos attentes
mais est-ce que c'est l'autre qui a
cessé de répondre à nos attentes
ou est-ce que c'est nous mêmes qui avons
construit des attentes que nous n'avions
pas à construire c'est nous mêmes qui
nous faisons des films c'est nous-mêmes
qui écrivons l'histoire de notre désir
l'autre n'en est que le support
d'inspiration
c'est vraiment très important de
comprendre cette idée maîtresse de la
conception du désir chez rousseau qui
est que le désir c'est notre tendance à
plaquer sur l'objet et en philosophie
lorsqu'on parle d'objets on parle aussi
bien de choses que de personnes a plaqué
sur l'objet des propriétés qui ne sont
pas ses propriétés à elle mais les
nôtres celles que nous souhaiterions
trouver en elle est donc en soi écrit
tout ce prestige disparaît devant
l'objet lui-même il veut dire par là que
lorsque nous sommes confrontés à la
réalité
et bien c'est à ce moment là que le
désir cesse et lorsque le désir cesse le
bonheur s'évanouit parce que nous ne
trouvons plus dans l'objet ce qui nous a
fait l'idéalisé et ce qui nous a fait
l'idéalisé c'est précisément le fait que
nous ne le connaissions pas que nous ne
le connaissions pas vraiment le désir
c'est le nuage d'illusions que nous
formons à partir d'un objet qui nous
inspire autrement dit le désirent se
nourrit du vide le désirent se nourrit
de l'ignorance c'est parce qu'on ignore
ce qu'est la chose que l'on va combler
cette ignorance par l'imagination et
qu'on va naturellement combler ce vide
par de la beauté et de l'idéal le désir
c'est l'ex
/ de notre besoin d'idéal
et c'est pour ça que rousseau se refuse
à condamner le désirent
parce qu'il n'ya pas à condamner la
tendance des êtres humains à vouloir
contempler le beau
la beauté qui fait le sens de la vie
c'est la beauté qui fait la valeur de la
vie malheur à qui n'a plus rien à
désirer
malheur à qui ne cherche plus le beau
malheur à qui renonce à l'idéal
malheur à qui se satisfait de la réalité
rousseau dans ses textes emprunte
parfois des accents romantiques
c'est quelqu'un qui valorise énormément
la recherche de l'absolu le goût de
l'infini le dépassement permanent de ce
qui est
c'est quelqu'un pour qui l'être humain
possède une qualité qui le distingue des
autres êtres de la nature
cette qualité c'est l'imagination
l'imagination dont s'abreuvent le désir
le désir qui lui fait accéder à l'idéal
est donc finalement tel est le paradoxe
que formulent rousseau à la fin de son
texte en disant que le pays des chimères
et en ce monde le seul digne d'être
habité le pays des chimères c'est
l'imagination c'est le pays des
illusions c'est celui où l'impossible à
sa place dans le pays des chimères on
n'exclut pas l'impossible on n'exclut
pas l'idéal au contraire on s'assoit à
sa table et on n'en partagent les fruits
le pays
en ce monde le seul digne d'être habité
et elle est le néant des choses humaines
encore l'être existants par lui-même il
n'y a rien de beau que ce qui n'est pas
tel est le paradoxe de l'existence qu'en
dehors de lettres que nous nous
efforçons de rejoindre en dehors de cet
absolu qui nous traverse et qui nous
dépasse il n'y a finalement rien de plus
beau que ce qui n'existe que dans notre
imagination
rien de plus beau que ce que nous créons
par notre imagination que ce que nous
créons par notre désir
notre désir est en notre effort pour
rejoindre le bo la force qui nous
conduit vers l'absolu la force qui nous
conduit vers l'idéal
la seule chose
soit aussi belle que l'être c'est le no
naître c'est ce que nous faisons être
c'est ce qui n'a pas besoin d'exister
pour être je vous remercie
[Musique]